donc Fab on est parti pour suivre cette
extraordinaire tournoi donc la finale du
chest.com Global Championship 2022 avec
énormément d'argent dans jeu c'est pour
un pour un tournant internet puisque
dans celui-ci il y a un million de
dollars de prix et on a on a tous les
tous les gros joueurs internet là qui se
sont qui se sont qualifiés pour pour ce
tournoi Fab le gratin est là on a pas de
bluff on a Nakamura évidemment qui qui
gagne qui gagne tous les tous les tous
les titles qui est toujours là bien
placé André Kin aussi très gros joueur
internet rajabov
voilà
qu'il y a un habitué des des joutes
internet Niall Sarine aussi on est tous
meilleurs joueurs sur sur chiasse.com
et quelques invités surprises j'ai envie
de dire deux Douda et egeri qui eux sont
moins habitués à assez juste là et aussi
ça me sévit en lui aussi habitué mais
qui s'était fait éliminé par par les
bonnes
pas pu venir finalement et donc qui
reprend en quelque sorte sa place mais
voilà une des spécialistes Fabien dans
dans ce dans ce tournoi et de deux
petites surprises et je te propose qu'on
suive pour le premier match du DA contre
camion ouais bah une grosse affiche non
alors comment on se joue le match Fab là
est-ce que tu te poses des est-ce que tu
es tu te poses ouais comment ça marche
sur deux jours trois jours semaine on ne
sait plus alors non c'est sûr deux jours
donc c'est en 15 + 2 donc la Ham 15
minutes tu joues ta partie hop tu as les
petites 2 secondes qui viennent de les
petites bouffées d'air pour souffler
quatre parties tous les jours donc
quatre parties aujourd'hui quatre
parties demain tac tac et il se passe
quoi si euh si il y a 4 4 Armageddon
enfin j'ai deux questions d'ailleurs
est-ce que c'est deux matchs différents
c'est la suite genre tu gagnes le
premier match 4-0 tu parles 2e 2 et demi
et demi oh là là c'est une bonne
question mais de ce que j'ai lu c'est le
même match attention ok d'accord parce
que j'ai eu c'est le même match et c'est
vrai que c'est c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne question c'est vrai qu'il y a des
questions Fab auxquelles j'ai pas non
mais moi j'ai lu que c'était 8 matchs
mais je me suis pas posé la question en
fait j'ai lu huit parties 15 + 2 les
parties débutent toutes les heures et en
cas de match nul on verra on verra
l'Armageddon bon alors cette ouverture
c'est une petite pétrole mais bonne
question pour pour le côté
enthousiasmant
maxenter ah non pas du tout pas
intéressé pour parler un million de
dollars Fabien ça plus attiré les les
les spécialistes de ces jours-là et il y
a des joueurs après moins habitués qui
ont tenté quand même leur chance je
pense à greachuk je pensais une VL aussi
qui est mon habitué mais ils ont pas
réussi à lutter et qui est le favori
alors je pense que ce son nacamura et
Douda qui se rencontrent au premier tour
pour moi les deux favoris donc là on a
dans cette ouverture une pétrole et qui
a été joué un petit peu dans le style
d'une Française d'échange genre pas tout
à fait ils ont pas fait la transposition
mais ça fait un petit peu ressembler ou
à une berlinoise Fabien et on voit les
blancs quand même nettement mieux ici
enfin nettement mieux un petit peu mieux
qui ont qui ont cet avantage long terme
c'est une structure effectivement
symétrique et donc quand c'est une
structure symétrique ce qui peut donner
l'avantage ou pas ça peut être le
placement des pièces et on voit donc les
blancs sont un peu plus actifs avec le
contrôle de la colonne 1 déjà avec la
tour dessus la seule que la nouvelle
ouverte et ils ont envoyé un cahier ça
qui pousse un pion h là pour aller un
peu ils ont provoqué le coucher 6
évidemment on peut éviter mat donc
peut-être voilà une petite initiative
pour les blancs après reste à voir si ça
peut être matérialisé on sait que Douda
est quand même un expert dans ses
pétrole c'est un moment qu'il les joue
et il connaît bien après moi tu me
montres la position comme ça je dis ah
bah c'est une réussite pour les blancs
cette ouverture mais tu vois il a pas
l'air trop sourciller
il a pris qu'une 30 pour jouer le début
bon après oui la case de 5 elle donne
envie
tu dis qu'il y a un peu des faiblesses à
droite à gauche que toi tu peux venir E5
E4 les Noirs n'auront pas parce qu'on
aura F3
donc ouais je préfère les blancs mais
avoir après ça peut se matérialiser
et par contre tu as un mauvais fou
ouais alors pareil relatif si je plante
en E5 il sera quand même pas mal mais tu
perds
tu peux le mettre et il sera il sera
beau quoi et le roi un peu faible
peut-être non tous ces Punto qui ont
avancé là un peu devant ou pas du tout
je sais pas trop
pour elle être après ben en gros dudat
il te dit bah j'ai donné mon coup de
caisse blanche du coup je mets les pions
sur caisse blanche pour pour compenser
donc il a mis les cavaliers aussi suivi
en taper en F4 en D4 écoute il fait un
peu sa vie de cavalier c'est un peu
moche en fait il y a trop de trous dans
la position les pions trop avancé donc
il prend une fois j'adore le coup de
l'ordi là le coup même cavalier G4
tellement jolie trouvable très trouvable
en fait
faut y penser mais c'est trouvable
tu veux juste venir 5 et si il prend tu
prends G6 cavalier G7 et
c'est trouvable c'est pas facile c'est
pas un coussin on va pas se mentir c'est
pas un coup facile cavalier 4 mais en 15
+ 2 quand tu as l'aisance tactique d'un
Nico c'est un coup qui est trouvable
plus trouvable même si c'était le seul
bon coup bah il le fait cavalier G4 mais
ouais ça sentait que c'était trouvable
ouais bien sûr c'est complètement dans
ses cordes bah en fait on a envie de
mettre un Cavaillon de 5 et il l'a bien
vu donc ouais bah ça a taper un peu G6
et en plus la troisième rangée dispo
maintenant pour que la dame coulisse
éventuellement slash la tour donc
voilà je me posais des questions parce
que des fois tu as des positions qui ont
l'air dégueulasse mais le mecs
connaissent tout par cœur ils ont fait
de l'ordi et en fait ça va bon ben là ça
juste l'air d'être vraiment pourri ouais
c'était c'est l'ouverture a complètement
été ratée et il se met tout de suite en
grand danger hein Douda parce que déjà
qui carou semble quand même le favori
sur le papier ou une défaite là alors
lors de cette première partie lui
mettrait vraiment un gros coup de bambou
derrière la tête et même peut-être
devant la tête d'ailleurs pourquoi le
coup de bambou devrait être que derrière
Fab partir intéressantes qui qui va qui
met à mal son adversaire
[Musique]
bon cela dit de la Coupe qu'à moitié
enfin sûrement que il va quand même
mettre le cavalier en E5 et sur quel
écran mettre le fou quoi c'est une
catastrophe bon les gens veulent la
barre des Vals comme c'est fait pour
écoute on va la mettre
une petite barre des Vals magnifique
cette barre des Vals elle va presque
dans le 5 quand même c'est pas rien qui
va dur 5 cavalier prend fou prends ça va
échanger dame j'ai trois cavalier F4
tour de toi j'ai l'impression que ça se
joue tout seul en plus comme position
c'est assez simple il n'y a pas besoin
de chercher des coups de ouf c'est que
des coups naturels
on voit que la barre ne bouge pas donc
c'est si on enlève tout le temps c'est
un petit peu monter ouais mais bon après
le truc c'est que c'est un petit peu
ou pas
non elle peut être à hauteur du 5 mais
je pense pas que ce sera tout en haut du
5 attends attends
il était content il était content alors
dit que ce soit joué on va dire on va
voir on va voir si ça monte si ça
descend au prochain coup Fab allez tour
pour doubler les tours pas bête mais la
barre qui reste à peu près mais moi je
pense que tout d'un coup elle va
s'envoler cette barre non peut-être pas
au coup prochain mais tout d'un coup ça
va
il y aura une connerie
[Musique]
C3 il en profite pas j'aurais besoin de
faire j'attendais conneries toi F7 ça va
ça maintient le
25 c'est lui qui joue au final
fab2 cavalier
il se fait grignoter il se fait
grignoter le genre américain
voilà mais bon après il peut faire une
guerre d'usure à se dire de toute façon
on t'a pendule elle restera elle restera
comme elle est quoi la part monter si
vite ça reste pas bête pour les longues
en fait il a envie de mettre le
calendrier en Détroit c'est pour ça que
la dame et que le cavalier vient de se
diriger soit en C5 soit la place du Fou
éventuellement la Dame des deux elle est
un peu chiante elle t'évite de doubler
les tours tu aurais bien aimé faire
peut-être te recettes mais bon bah tu
couvre ton fou donc j'ai 5 sera en prise
et donc il te cumulent des petits trucs
chiants alors que ok l'ordi ça va perdre
l'impressionnait il va te défendrait
mais humainement ça renforce en fait il
a doublé les tours sur la colonne
ouverte il ramène son cavalier qui était
à l'aise il va le mettre en Détroit donc
en fait en soi c'est pas c'est pas mal
hein tu vois j'imagine qu'il y ait des
trois maintenant
sur la position c'est terrible pour pour
Jean-Christophe qui suit
mais voilà ça y est ça rentre dans le 6
Fab ouais c'est pas mon signe ça c'était
sûr en fait ça peut pas du tout marcher
ce qu'il fait chaos qui va encore
marcher sur le tournoi ouais je pense
qu'il va le gagner très facilement ce
tournoi personnellement maintenant
là-bas partie va juste à blog Guy BOV
c'est viande Sarine c'est sûr que non
peut-être bien je sais pas s'il est très
sérieux bien préparé que tu prends pas
trop lamentage c'est pas une séance trop
rapide en 15 minutes tu peux peut-être
un peu mais bon il est moins fort en 15
minutes tu es sûr que que peut-être
peut-être sur un petit peu match et là
la position elle est en train de
s'effriter côté noir comme tu l'as
expliqué il y a maintenant une vingtaine
de minutes c'est un petit peu le la
résultante de ce que tu disais bah ouais
bon on laisse jamais 8 déjà gagné une
pièce et ben on a complètement le
contrôle de la colonne c'est 5 très
pénible attaque B7 il est défendu mais
tu vois ça fait juste une faiblesse en
plus
tu as le droit gérer tu as la huitième
manche à gérer ta beaucoup de choses en
vérité là vous avez la joie à gauche
mais à ce moment ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'elle soit déjà dans le 7 voire même
dans le 8 ça c'est c'est trop là
c'est 6 ok là ce qu'il y a à trouver
c'est qu'il prend B7 mais c'est assez
facile
ouais dame prendre 8 3 G7 fois 8 que les
prend et tout recettes et on gagne et on
gagne après on a donné pas le matériel
mais on va quand même bouffer pas mal de
pions ils vont être faible alors ça
c'est
bon
en même temps en fait il y a souvent de
liquide
[Musique]
vraiment spécialiste aussi internet
il s'accroche avec les Blancs il fait ce
qu'il peut c'est un peu durer car ou qui
a trouvé
l'enchaînement lequel il prend B7 on
peut vous remettre si vous voulez
donc c'est cet enchaînement dont on
parlait c'était sûr
voilà et là le truc c'est qu'il va
commencer à gober tous les pions
pas si simple à défendre attention après
le seul truc enfin qui peut arriver si
tu fais genre kg 6 cavalier F4 tu as
tout qui se défend
ouais
[Musique]
on sait jamais aussi mais bon
normalement ça va jamais trop passer
tout ça ah attention menace oh là là si
tu fais dames c'est 8 la barre s'envole
non
et là si tu fais genre dames c'est un
j'ai trois la barre s'envole ou pas on
essaye
attention quand même
d'ailleurs il est un peu va attendre
avant de le faire le il a fait mais
c'est pas sûr qu'il gagne en fait
elle m'a pas l'air d'être si simple
celle-là alors
cavalier H7 f64
alors peut-être ouais c'est trop peu
arrivé
[Musique]
de l'autre côté mais bon ça va pas être
facile
elle serait peut-être nulle oui
mais même là elle est pas enfin pas sûr
que fondamentalement elle soit gagnante
non mais bon entre le temps et tout ça
il y a trop de problèmes mais si tu as
beaucoup de temps je pense que tu as des
chances de la défendre ça là le truc
c'est qu'en fait il faut qu'il faudrait
qu'il réussisse à laisser les pions
avancer en F5 et G4 mettre le fou sur sa
diagonale et faire le blocus allez il
faut cliquer
le cheval non
ah il veut cliquer comme ça je pense
qu'il veut cliquer jusqu'en E4 donc il
veut pas rebouger son cheval mais là il
menace pas cavalière cette
malheureusement pas encore
ça clique ça va ça y est il joue
beaucoup mieux depuis qu'il clique ah
bah oui là il fait quelques bons coups
la barre est beaucoup plus dans le 5
bravo quoi ah ça joue bien un côté
côté Jean-Christophe là
à droite à gauche et il va essayer
d'attendre faut savoir que tant que
toutes les pièces se protègent il peut
rien t'arriver contre quand tu joues
contre une dame tu peux pas dire double
attaque il peut y avoir des échecs ou
c'est tout mais bon ça ça va c'est pas
grave
alors là ça va être le problème
maintenant c'est qu'il va devoir cliquer
des deux côtés
normalement il devrait quand même la
perdre malheureusement mais enfin
malheureusement
tant mieux pourri Caro hein les deux
secondes c'est quand même très différent
des une seconde parc ou un saclass quand
même envie tu souffles plus tu souffles
un peu ouais une seconde tu remontes pas
ouais tu as pas le temps de voir
de voir le jour
mais le pion assis s'il a fait un bel
effort ici
il pourra pas arrêter les puntos des
deux côtés ça va gagner pour Ikaru t'es
trop petites
[Musique]
ça va être terminé trop
à gauche ça fait ça fait une première
victoire
ouais donc soit perdu ou il est en train
de perdre
un chat plusieurs vies cette vie je
crois donc
c'est quoi cette plus il y a 100 pions
avec les Blancs il fait échec
contre André Kim bon a priori il s'en
sort bien saut parce qu'on voit ce qu'on
a vu cru voir on a la jauge hein
nouveau relativement contente pour pour
les blancs qui pourtant un pion de moins
mais elles sont bien centralisées qui
attaquent le pion E5 c'était quoi juste
l'ouverture
c'est une nouvelle nulle Fab et donc il
va rester Niall Sarine la partie
excitante contre sévi
mais les blondes doivent être un peu
mieux voilà paire de fou de colonne
vertes bon c'est mieux 3 mais bon 2
c'est déjà quelque chose et avoir s'il
arrive à travailler cette position petit
à petit
de toute façon
tu as le fou quoi mais il va faire non
mais il va faire nul
en fait
résumer une victoire des carreaux et
que des nuls aux autres échiquier
ensuite
alors les amis ça part j'ai coupé Fab la
bande-annonce parce que ça partait et
bah écoute priorité au direct priorité
au direct par contre pas le
bande-annonce donc on a une petite
petite
en face donc bon il va regagner ces
quatre mais tu lâches un peu la case B4
aussi en contrepartie donc bon KF3 c'est
4 E4 plus si j'ai envie de faire
n'importe quoi je veux G3 premiers coups
ou je sais pas quoi c'est bon sur ce
cavalier C3 désolé fables j'ai vu la
jauge qui tout d'un coup ah ah ah ah ah
il y a pas aimé
mais là encore il semble enfin au vu de
la jauge moi je me fie à la jauge Fab
io les noirs et résolu leurs problèmes
d'ouverture complètement donc cavalier à
de jouer qui va jouer le coup B6 et on
voit cette jauge après B6 qui remonte
pas du tout le coup un coup qui n'a pas
bien jaugé donc là non bah écoute on va
voir là bon il a éventuellement un petit
avantage peut-être à faire valoir
va falloir être précis mais bon bah déjà
le plus on s'éclate peut être récupéré
tu peux gagner aussi la paire de fou en
prenant B4 d'abord peut-être donc avoir
tu peux enchaîner les deux en fait
je sais pas si c'est fou à 6 qui est
prévu Paris chaos pour s'activer quand
même ce fou viser vers eux et du coup
peut-être avec les ventes autre chose
avant genre c'est trop rien un coup
peut-être comme tourner un peu être
envisageable parce que tu as bien envie
de faire quel lieu cinq peut-être après
tu as créé un vis-à-vis etc
donc possible possible pour D1 mesdames
prends ces quatre
d'abord et d'un me prend ces quatre dans
la foulée
quand même prendre ce fou avant laisser
en ville en béca j'aime pas trop
bon peut-être qu'il aime pas ramener le
pion à 5 en B4
ouais bon enfin c'est quand même un fou
quoi bah qu'il aurait pris sans trop
sortir
ouais non mais bon oui ça me manque
peut-être de cohérence mais on va voir
après les blancs bon c'est pas si débile
il va il va vraiment prendre ces quatre
quand même un jour parce qu'à force de
le laisser dans le défendre et puis tu
vas jamais le revoir et puis peut-être
faire quatre jours pour le skate des 5
alors certes ça te ferment un peu le
fougereux ça te prend quand même de
l'espace et on va voir tu vois mais là
il va se rendre B5 à force de pas le
manger
après c'est position elles sont quand
même agréables à jouer même avec un pion
de moi tu as le centre ici avec le blanc
tu as la paire de fou tu as quand même
de beaux arguments à faire valoir et on
sait que maintenant on aime bien
avantage enfin la compensation à long
terme c'est compensation à long terme
c'est catalan qui a été remis au goût du
jour par magne-nous scarlsen l'ex
champion du monde depuis deux jours il a
officiellement rendu son titre c'est
écrit
donc là on a plus de champion du monde
on a plus de champion du monde
actuellement ok 50 ans après Bobby
Fischer
du monde d'échec lui aussi qui bat un
Russe exactement comme le match Fisher
spaski un titre de 960 rempli de de
symboliques
qui est maintenant l'équivalent quelque
sorte de Bobby Fischer
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que que
Douda patoche un peu dans la semoule en
fait c'est pas évident avec les Blancs
il est chiant quoi donc
en fait je veux bien croire qu'un ordi
peut-être est très heureux d'avoir un
pion de moi mais en fait je sais pas
enfin au bout d'un moment c'est énervant
humainement quoi il est là en C4 il te
bloque ta colonne C il est chiant ce
pion que enfin elle était mieux prendre
en fait et revenir
tu l'as pas récupéré
après les noirs peuvent pas non plus
faire grand-chose pour le moment mais
enfin je sais pas tu fais tout à 7 tours
des 7 B 5
conditions ça va tourner
faut peut-être faire un petit coup de
prépa pour éviter qu'il G4 et avancer
non
ouais alors je sais pas pour arriver à
avancer mais pourquoi pas avec EF4 F4 F5
aussi un jour peut-être ou tu peux aller
en G6 en fait c'était une stratégie de
laisser le pion pour que tu le défendes
regarde tu perds du temps tu te
décalages
après ouais bon peut-être qu'il y a un
truc qui bon il a fait je trouve un truc
qui peut peut-être l'embêter c'est E5
des noirs pour bloquer un peu de
distance et pourquoi pas ramener le
crédit R3 voilà du coup bon après je
sais pas si ko de faire ce 5 ou pas ou
je vais faire des tours D8 et compagnie
mais
voilà moi il fait trop vite ok donc bon
on imagine qu'il veut faire F4
maintenant voilà ça évite les G4 donc du
coup je dois préparatoire et on consomme
la marée
ça permet aussi peut-être de faire dame
F2 et G4 si besoin ou
peut-être F5 un moment enfin on va voir
ça lui donne pas mal d'options exception
en tout je pense qu'il carot il va
envoyer un B5 à un moment donné
ouais il va falloir réagir un moment
parce que si tu fais trop rien
ouais ça va ça va dérouler
visuellement
tu tapes là t'empêche laisser 5
t'empêche ça t'empêche le 5
tu couvrages 4 F4 tu fais G4
donc ça fait multifonctions
en fait bon on va voir il a une position
pas trop mal quand même
ça donne la case des 5 faut toujours
faire attention et d'un autre côté le
cavalier est parti il y a l'autre il
pourrait y aller il peut faire ça aussi
peut se replacer les cavaliers de
manière un peu bizarre
après ouais donc 5 ouais donc là je des
5 tu te donnes tu donnes 4 en échange et
éventuellement des 6/7 pour faire des
combines
ok bon on va voir ça devient tout d'un
coup beaucoup plus concret
comme tout
maintenant ça donne un plan comme rouage
2 tours géant fou F3 et bim quoi
aussi c'est des plans comme ça donc il
s'est dit ok je bloque et tout ce qui
espère c'est qu'il y a un
G3 mal timé et qui puisse planter un
cavalier là et tenir sur les cases
blanches avec des blocus mais bien sûr
Douda va pas le faire s'il prend F5 ça
montre lequel il peut pas prendre ou
alors
j'ai enfin que tu as mis tout ton truc
en place tu mets la semaine des G5 il y
aura plus H5 et tu peux ouvrir
donc ouais ma foi s'appelle air con
c'est juste qu'il faut jouer un peu plus
vite parce que là c'est un plan entre
guillemets stratégique et tu as
quasiment tes trois prochains coups
ouais je vois pas trop
quand tu fais j'ai 5 ou pas
il a passé 5 tours je trouve que c'est
très bizarre mais
bon ok pourquoi enfin je sais pas
pourquoi ce stade de coup mais si c'est
pour faire H2 dame je sais pas où j'ai
trois H4 et glisser deux tours pourquoi
pas
ok donc tu aurais fuite c'est bon ben on
maintient peut-être du un coup de dames
un coup de F3 en tout cas
ça s'en va la gauche
bon après le coup après je sais pas
pourquoi
je vois pas de coup qui défonce d'un
coup mais après
en cavalier prend et fouger 2 et ça
s'envole l'autre en plus qui est pas
forcément le truc logique quoi donc ok
donc ça c'était logique mais ouais c'est
con qui autant pour jouer l'écologie
mais parce qu'en plus la sensation que
c'est des coups tu les joues dans un
ordre dans l'autre après c'est sûr qu'il
a de prendre une peau de banane mais là
je crois que c'était pas le cas de
figure où ça pouvait réellement arriver
et il a peut-être jeté deux trois
minutes à la poubelle qui pourrait être
cruciale en fin de partie bah oui oui
personnellement
j'ai 5 h 5 et bien bloqué et pouvoir
réagir donc ok il va se mettre en place
pour les sacrifier là-bas on va voir le
taux un oranger de et il va consacrer G5
et je prends F pourquoi pas faire
cailler des uns et je vais vous trois
vous venez manger trois voilà très bien
[Musique]
de tempo allez Jean-Christophe il faut
se bouger là de toute façon cette tour
elle a plus rien à faire sur la colonne
des en réalité
tu vois tu peux aussi calculer des G5
déjà à la même si j'y crois pas trop
mais oui
c'est des cas de figures où tu pourrais
casser avoir des sacrifices de dames
mais là je vois pas dans quel cas mais
même des dames prends H6 dans certains
cas à c'est incroyables peuvent marcher
avec
pour placer
pour aller retaper sur la diagonale se
met en face du roi
mais bon il va falloir percer la
capacité maintenant c'est pas fait il
est mieux ça c'est ok on le voit la
jauge confirme mais ok il a tout bien
agglutiné là-bas et c'est pas simple il
a pas de maths pour le moment
jouer quand même je trouve
un petit souci un moment
c'est une tête de bon coup et là tu vois
c'est là que ça ça le fait pas 45
secondes pour pour Jean-Christophe
comme prévu
et du coup tu prends il reprend il se
sécurise le pion tu peux pas prendre ces
quatre il y a ton four en l'air il va
faire pousser un truc j'imagine ouais
mais est-ce que c'est pas
mais peut-être ça à ce moment-là que ça
devient pas trop clair mais bon ok c'est
quand même pas mal il y avait un coup
peut-être simple je vais vite c'était
tour G3 juste en fait tu t'enlèves
mais tu vois le tour qui le coup qu'il a
peut-être perdu avec ton des deux tours
G2 au lieu de faire genre ton jeu un
tour j'ai trois tours géant pas à se
mettre directement la tour bien bon
après les Caro aurait probablement pas
fait ça à ce moment-là mais quand même
c'est des petits détails tu vois que ta
tour elle est mieux mais bon il aurait
pas eu d'1 m2 ok on peut aller bouffer
ces quatre j'imagine ouais mais c'est là
qu'il te faut plus de temps parce que
contre ricaru on est d'accord quand même
que dans la tête même pour des joueurs
du calibre de Douda tu es tu prends un
peu plus de temps pour jouer des coups
comme dame français 4 contre un tel
ou deux fois plus voilà faut prendre de
la tour
il a une idée
d'enflure c'était sûr eh mais bon c'est
obligatoire il en a toujours une de plus
ah c'était malin ce dame D8
du coup ouais il a la structure qui
voulait avec les Noirs après bon tu
restes avec des faiblesses partout F2
pour focaliser et tenir cette case H4 ça
peut être important puis on voit ce qui
avait dit OK
[Musique]
elle est terrible la position pour les
Noirs mais bon plus que 21 secondes pour
Jean-Christophe
twenty one seconds for Jean-Christophe
comme ils doivent être en train de dire
là sur le stream en anglais en américain
bon ils doivent être comme des fous
furieux là donc Christophe cas sa
position C5
prix du pion du pied
ça commence à suer pour le joueur
américain G6
quand même je pense je sais pas s'il y a
une tactique qui termine la partie
derrière mais
ça peut pas être mal il va aller bouffer
B5 qui a validé 6 bah c'est pas con non
plus ça protège
[Musique]
ça peut pas être con
OK
c'est bien joué il va sûrement faire
deux il est en train de digérer le pion
de plus là et après il va essayer
d'envoyer B6 je suppose un Fab pour
l'instant il y a toujours pas de contre
jeux pour les Caro mais il va peut-être
te faire un G5 un moment un truc un
arrache comme ça elle est il faut
cliquer
j'ai peur que le temps lui manque
tellement dur pour tricaro pour
l'instant je gère bien en tout cas mais
oui enfin il y a plus de 12 secondes
donc comme on disait tout à l'heure il
finit qu'à partir avec que des réflexes
et donc c'est un monde très précis tu
peux pas enfin c'est ce sera le hasard
quoi
c'est la bonne nouvelle ouais mais après
il est plus à l'aise car ou quand même
allez il faut jouer plus de 7 secondes
d'âme C6 un peu pleutre
Ikarus un spécialiste ça de te de te
pousser
de te tenter dans la poterie de te la
tenir il a piégé bah qui plus d'une fois
et c'est souvent un truc qui fait le
problème c'est que là en fait il se fait
plus matcher là ça va durer longtemps
maintenant
c'est typique typique et Caro
c'est en fait tu fous le bordel et après
tu donnes un backdoor qui est qui permet
d'échanger les pièces un genre de truc
psychologique il est presque il menace
pas vraiment maths encore c'est
chauffable ton G2 attends j'ai deux
c'est le coup de l'ordi c'est hyper fort
j'ai un c'est moins fort allez tourger
de le faire par ouais par obligation tu
repenser de intermédiaire il l'a pas si
là
il va il va la perdre en fait il va
juste la perdre en fait
il se fait intercepter le fou
quand même Fab plus que 6 secondes pour
IKO
il se barre avec le roi il monte oui il
va la perdre c'est terrible ouais c'est
terrible maintenant c'est les noirs qui
jouent le gars
faible immédiatement et
là il y a tout qui devient faible il y a
B3 qui va tomber et oui retourne aide
mais mérité quand même parce que il a il
a trop réfléchi à des moments où il
était pas obligé et il rate une
opportunité en or
mais là maintenant il a il a deux pions
moins à moins d'une arnaque légendaire
une petite petite fourchette un petit
machin mais bon
peut-être qu'il y a pas à perdre au
final enfin il est moins bien quoi
évidemment mais il a plus que moi son
cavalier était tellement mal placé il
faut qu'il réussisse ça le ramener allez
là il va peut-être y arriver enfin allez
le cheval allez Leval show il sort de
l'écurie
il est dans le très dur il est dans le
très dur bah ce serait dommage parce que
ce serait quasiment fin de match quoi et
c'est un peu bon sur le papier le seul
match intéressant du premier tour quand
même enfin c'est celui que tu as
vraiment envie de suivre ben moi d'être
supporter l'un des autres mais bon
c'est les deux plus beaux joueurs du
tournoi d'entrée qui s'affrontent donc
c'est oui c'est sûr que c'est dommage si
ce machin est déjà plié en fait
on va être supporter de Douda mais ouais
il va pas la tenir et surtout qu'il
était tellement bien
[Musique]
et oui
il est encore là-bas
en fait ce cavalier non mais il va bien
aussi
c'est bien battu ouais c'est plus ouais
c'est notre attaquant là qui vont lui il
a vraiment l'air perdu sur le terrain
c'est dur c'est peut-être pintor
il se fait il est pas trop bien non donc
là c'est qualité de moi et position
pourrie et plus de temps
bon ça fait beaucoup de défauts tout ça
ça pourrait
c'est marrant priori en portugais ça
veut dire peintre on nous dit quoi mais
bon
[Musique]
et là il y a pas de souci
elle a l'air sympa quand même ouais dame
de 4 pour éviter d'âme des 7
échecs pour défendre l'option E5 et
c'était l'espagnol et Douda je choisis
de jouer
une berlinoise
[Musique]
il a match il a match quasi perdu entre
guillemets
pourquoi tu vas t'embêter en tout cas
les carreaux est très tranquille après
peut-être qu'il connaît pas d'où hein
donc pourquoi pas
tu as déjà un peu plus donc tu rends ton
positif tu fais que rendre moi je ferais
fou aussi peut-être je veux garder ton
tour de plus
enfin tu veux prendre je me fais des
pions doublés je suis enfin je suis
content en fait
maximaliste entre guillemets ou tu veux
garder ton campus
[Musique]
ou
donc on va voir est-ce que tu fais à 5
ou pas sinon tu fais quoi tu fais
cavalier F5
[Musique]
c'est pas clair comme position Naka qui
réfléchit qui a été vite fait à 5 il
m'en faut à 7 ça va être joué de façon
il a pas le choix
cavalie F5 s'est joué aussi c'est assez
logique il menace rien de concret avec
les blancs mais le truc c'est que il a
tout l'espace
et les noirs sont un peu ligotés la tour
à 8 peut pas rentrer en jeu qui avait
c'est peut-être un coup mais moi il y a
peut-être cavalier 7 3 7 h 3 fois H5 G4
fougères 6
ce genre de choses qui est plongée 6 roi
prend ça a l'air de tenir mais il y a
peut-être un truc dans
dans ces ordres là de coups qui peut
gêner et là il fait cavailler
4 qui est bon aussi
bon comme quoi vous prend ici ce que je
n'arrivais pas à trouver c'était pas si
facile
puisque Douda après 6 minutes de
réflexion de la pas vu
et ça va être ça va faire encore Punto
alors il rentre dans le foot couleur
opposé donc tu parlais mais qu'on n'a
pas vu je vais remonter les coups faut
prendre F5 et prend F5 puis on prend
puis on prend puis on prend puis on
prend il faut prendre tu auras des 1
ouais bon du coup celui qui on va gagner
soit il y aura nul mais déjà il y a
aucun danger dans le sens inverse et tu
es un peu mieux parce que
tu as une tour qui va rentrer alors ça
peut être un peu étonnant de vous dire
ça il y a les pions sur case noire et
vous pouvez vous dire oui il a le
fossile fous sur 15 ans mais le truc
c'est qu'on peut pas
et le problème c'est que sur le seul
moyen de limiter les tours
fuite mais tu échange ta faute
donc là on doit échanger normalement
c'est en faveur des noirs de jouer pour
la nul en faisant ça mais on va se
perdre un pion alors après peut-être on
peut tenir la nulle dans cette finale
mais bon il faudra galérer quoi
c'est peut-être même la meilleure option
d'ailleurs de rentrer dans cette finale
et de ce des carcasses mais bon bah en
fait en général quand il y a tout sur le
monde clairement les chances de gains et
que quand il y a que des fous donc par
principe tu as envie de faire mais ouais
bon tu as le permis
de la diagonale moi j'ai le droit vient
en E4 et [ __ ] enfin
moi je pensais qu'elle est perdante
personnellement
qui sera passé peut-être tu dois vite
faire le 4 3 bon je sais pas trop si
c'est si gênant toute façon il se fait
arrêter facilement le fou va venir en
Détroit va monter c'est quoi la règle de
la Diego bah que le four en fait il
arrête les pions sur la même diagonale
tu dois tenir et si les cartelets bah tu
vas en pousser un pour le faire bouger
d'un côté et que l'autre il parte c'est
par exemple s'il devait s'il doit
défendre contre à 5 et C3 bah il va
rester là et il va enfin B en fait il va
bloquer le le fou il va se planter sur
une diagonale il va bloquer les deux
mais là le problème c'est que si tu as
le pion a passé le pion g en fait le fou
pour bloquer les deux il va devoir se
mettre sur une diagonale et quand il
aura chopé un l'autre avancera quoi
et c'est plus difficile de faire des
défenses combinées roi fou aussi dans
ces cas-là donc voilà après parce que le
roi il peut plus facilement venir aider
le fou et bloquer le 3 si des fois que
sur une diagonale
j'avais fait une master light là dessus
que vous pouvez retrouver sur Youtube ou
c'est hyper bien expliqué
la Master light ouais c'est très bien
très très bien expliqué il reste déjà
plus que 5 minutes à Douda c'est sur la
chaîne principale sur la chaîne
principale tu imagines 3-0 il va
peut-être peut-être que au bout de 5
parties de notre est fini quoi demain on
est 18h on est tranquille ok donc il
rentre dans la fameuse finale donc il va
retourner
et il va prendre à 6 et donc le plan des
blancs c'est de c'est monter le rang E4
et donc avec les noms a priori c'est
bien de vivre tous ces pions
reste là et que tu mets le rang E4 que
tu transfert après le fou et que tu
décides de quelques enfin tu pars du
côté que tu peux après ça va être
catastrophique à part principalement
c'est 5 ok alors
pousser B5 pour te faire le pion et
échange en échangeant moins
6 le rang E4 et réussir à ramener un
pion là-bas en G6 et c'est gagnant tu
mettras le fond E4 tu partiras d'un côté
avec le roi il sera protégé tu gagneras
peut-être qu'il espère te laisser que
avec Cash et donner le fou contre a quoi
mais bon ça a l'air d'être complètement
à cas de figure improbable ouais bon ok
du coup tu fais baisser
soit je me demande même si tu fais ton
roi des trois je suis pas contre c'est
BCB à béab un cours 4 on va dire qu'il
fait fout des 4 et tu pousses un peu
là-bas un peu les deux côtés je sais pas
ouais mais il doit vouloir te les te
forcer à partir avec le roi vers B
etc
et du coup pour éviter peut-être je fais
ABB 5 quoi
comme ça je garde le C3 en vie et ça
existe plus ce truc et l'ordi propose de
faire fouter 7 et sur CB il fait quoi il
fait à 6
mais comment il a fait avant juste en
fait
du coup tu veux échanger les pions ouais
il te fait 6 et prises et en fait il te
bloque il va te ramener le rang enfin
genre
en fait il va t'en faire enfin tu seras
obligé de faire B5 et du coup il obtient
ce qu'il veut obtenir quoi de toute
façon tu as même ton roi là-bas
il a tenté de faire la même chose il a
compris il a fait fou B5
Abassi il a compris et G4 c'est terminé
et en fait quand tu ramènes le roi
le truc qui est sale c'est que tu
enferme le fou donc il pourra pas
sacrifier c'est très bien joué
c'est pour ça que j'aurais fait vite B5
dans l'autre je pouvais ça aurait
peut-être changé mais tu sens que il est
bien bien
ça c'est joli c'est bien fait ouais bon
bah ça fait trois zéro Fab
oh il danse ça y est
le match est plié abandon
mama mia défonce
eux ils ont l'air d'être à l'heure alors
après c'est peut-être son nom mais c'est
la première ouais
OK
ah mais c'est magnifique en fait crieda
[Musique]
mais bon les joueurs ont quand même pris
cette mode hein de faire ces trucs là de
Shia la gueule du public de ceux qui les
payent
le caca quoi c'est bien qu'est-ce que tu
veux c'est tant qu'il y a pas de
sanction et tout le monde trouve ça
normal moi j'ai déjà eu le débat sur les
4 5 2 recettes de Nakamura
et que c'est drôle ben ouais ok mais pas
tellement enfin moi j'ai jamais trouvé
ça drôle que disons non mais pourquoi
c'est enfin tant mieux pour eux enfin
après on se retrouve avec des
accusations de n'importe enfin c'est le
résultat en fait de tout ça on est dans
le grand n'importe quoi tu défends plus
tes titres de champs enfin tu fais
n'importe quoi de A à Z et puis c'est
forcément on a l'impression que le monde
c'est enfin c'est pas truut c'est pas
Twitter quoi c'est pas faire de blague
enfin je sais pas j'ai pas l'impression
quand je regarde du tennis ou quoi on se
[ __ ] de ma gueule comme ça mais après
non non mais ça a des conséquences mais
non dans l'exemplarité que tu donnes aux
plus jeunes ou à la relève au futur
génération en tout cas c'est
c'était pas ça quoi mais je veux dire tu
prends tous les champions du passé ils
ont jamais fait ça quoi non mais jamais
fait la on a perdu fabutier je veux des
trucs pareils en plus mais il se love
votre vinique Stains
non mais tu vois ça me fait un peu
penser comme si au tennis à un moment
donné tu avais je sais pas tu avais un
match entre deux mecs Roland-Garros ou
je sais pas n'importe quel tournant en
fait on s'en fout et que les mecs pour
rigoler se donner deux trois jours que
des doubles fautes et Il se marrait
j'ai fait 10 double fautes ils sont
assis ici si je vous le tie break et il
savait avec un peu mais en fait si tu
faisais ça ben
juste tu serais viré enfin genre les le
public te cracherait dessus en fait
c'est ça possible et amande du tournoi
et Machin et puis il y a des
conséquences peut-être tu perds tes
sponsors enfin il se passe des choses en
fait mais bon si aux échecs c'est bien
continuons aux échecs ça fait rire mais
bon j'ai envie de te dire si c'était le
problème principal des échecs ça on
serait aussi très bien parce que c'est
un problème
c'est un symptôme tout le temps ouais
c'est qu'en fait les institutions sont
pas fortes quoi et laisse tout faire
tout et n'importe quoi
ah bah oui mais bon c'est ça ça de
grosse conséquences après mais bon non
mais tennis
une exhibition donc là ils sont contents
ils sont faire des smatchs ils défendent
des fois il passe de trait du filet mais
en fait ils ont rien à [ __ ] de qui
viennent qui perd c'est pas un tournoi
là il se trouve c'est un tournoi il y a
un million de prix en fait enfin
c'est de l'argent en fait
ça va
pas pour tout le monde apparemment non
apparemment pas pour tout le monde
c'est très bien
il passe sous le Baby au vu de ah il a
pris 5-0 ce serait beau hein étendez un
ok mais parce qu'il a bien calculé
tourner
il a gardé du temps et surtout surtout
H2 il veut désolé il veut peut-être tout
rare
et du coup roi B2 tours ici mais tu es
content tu économises un tempo
ils sont forts quand même
quelque part mais bon avec peu de temps
faut que me faire gaffe avec le cavalier
passe le faire après tu as des cases
quand même
tu vas bouffer à trois pour le moment il
est pseudo-défendu par des tours à deux
quand même
tomber 5 mais je veux dire faut faire
gaffe de que la fin que la tour se
retrouve pas bloquée du coup le cavalier
enfin tu m'as compris quoi
est-ce que j'ai pas une autre option en
fait je pense qu'il va bouffer non
je pense aussi
tu sais pas si tu gagnes un temps ou pas
j'imagine alors tu qui viennent de se
doute c'est un c'est une position
et tu gardes le pion C3 en vue non mais
c'est probablement plus fort mais juste
moi je suis assez pleutre et j'ai envie
d'aller au 5 pour faire quelques il me
paraît de là j'en ai marre je veux plus
voir ce qu'il y a c'est ce qu'il a fait
aussi mais c'est repartir merci
ça dépend des variantes en fait
ok cavalier
c'est fou quand même comment ce coup ça
c'est pas ça se sentait que tu vas le
payer un jour en fait
peut-être tu as de la chance tu le
paieras pas trop mais ça te complique la
vie
je pense qu'il doit tenter roi B4 ou
apprend à 4 de toute façon
il fait roi F5
et tu vas la gagner de mer X ou Y celle
là
et puis bah voilà c'est tout bah oui
parce qu'au pire le roi il passe par là
tu fais C5 B5 tu as l'impression que tu
fais un mur mais 5 enfin c'est fini
et tu as le décalage par là-bas et s'il
y a en B6 tu feras B4 à 3 et c'est
terminé
merci au revoir ce sera Sona caméra elle
a deux points d'avance c'est
c'est eux c'est la même partie de
tableau ouais ouais ok
ça c'est sûr et du coup il faut voir le
bas du tableau maintenant Fab euh
Raja Bob bon ça c'est complètement
ok on peut rester dessus c'est pas le
temps de changer les noms c'est rajabaf
avec les Blancs bah s'il gagne en fait
c'est Vian il tue le match aussi
+ 2 c'est trop c'est pas mal ça peut
faire de finir tôt demain quoi
à mon avis ça va ça va aller au bout de
la nuit il est vraiment
à 3 non je sais pas prise d'17 est-ce
que il veut tomber vite sinon
poursuit on s'en fout
pas facile à voir ça non mais c'est ce
que je veux questionner en fait je me
dis c'est ça qui veut aussi après nous
on a la jauge qui facilite quand même
pas que je comprends que ça va pour les
Noirs mais du coup ça te fait quelques
temps B8 ou quoi mais peut-être ton eau
de vente elle est pas bête avec le A3 je
sais pas
en fait c'est pour faire à 3 à 2 et kb3
et essayer de juste passer le pion en
fait
tu vas devoir rentrer là-dedans ok bon
c'est très bien ouais mais ça c'est pas
si facile enfin c'est pas si facile non
mais bon
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il a fait 8 ok
il a pas vu juste
c'est trop je pense pour remonter ouais
bah ok
des quatre
c'est trop facile c'est un truc comme ça
bon ça va aller c'est beaucoup trop
facile ça va peut-être faire nul
finalement
qui est de justesse mais
chat qui perd les casques qui contrôle
la donc
voilà après il y a quand même beaucoup
de fourchettes possibles et il peut pas
s'en prendre enfin en fait un cavalier
peut pas mettre une fourchette un autre
cavalier c'est important
mais après
il va faire tout rage 4 non je pense
bien placé
facilement en plus malheureusement pour
lui il menace m'attendre quand même
après tu comprends rien
un peu de suspense dans ce match quand
même Fab
là c'est un peu comme Raja
ils sont en souffrance mais il
s'accroche
ils font ce qu'il peut faut pas pas tout
perdre attention quand même ce qu'il a
le roi sur la bande dès le début
même si c'est complètement nul c'est sûr
[Musique]
donc il y a deux matchs qui sont déjà
quasi pliés c'est Nakamura Douda et
Wesley Sow André Kin avec respectivement
4 points et deux points d'avance et de
matchs qui sont encore chauds avec un
seul point d'avance c'est Annie Giri qui
mène deux et demi contre teamoradja bof
et ça me séviant qui mène 2 et demi un
et demi contre NiAl Sarine merci à toi
mon Fab à demain ciao ciao